are they not showing those those I guess
the more people would say no yeah why
yeah I might guess my my assumption of
it is obviously there's that side of it
but also like if you've gone there and
you've said like
I don't want to keep this baby based on
my mental health from a psychologist's
stance would it be good for your mental
health to then show you an extremely
graphic image or procedure when you've
already decided that you don't want that
yeah like at what point does it become
protection of your mental health which
is the reason why you went in the first
place 100 because if your mental health
is bad now and then you you have an
abortion and see what the hell is going
on here it's going to get way worse than
it already was yeah yeah 100 like
imagine if it before imagine if if your
mental health was bad like you're
depressed and anxious everything and
then they they for example you don't get
shown the video right and then you have
the abortion and then you you become
more depressed because like if you if
they actually just gave you that warning
sign like okay look here's what it looks
like here's what it's going to be here's
what it might happen his you know you
kind of would consider it like oh I
think my mental health would get way
worse and I feel like let me just try
and give it a go you know I think it's
you to believe that intention isn't to
protect your mental health on any level
and that's the why they've not decided
to show you the pictures despite all
three counseling services do you think
intention matters
if the outcome is is if the out does
intention matter if the outcome is women
not being informed about a medical
procedure I think that it's important to
be objective and understand as to why
that decision was made like subjectively
obviously
being explained magical procedures may
be a good implementation in that process
would be to be given the choice do you
want to see this do you know I don't
know if that is an option or not whether
you actually are given that choice no
it's not but I feel like if we because
obviously if I've come to a doctor and
said like I'm experiencing XYZ and I'm
suffering and I can't do this and I
don't want this
mental health tick they're not gonna
then just like oh and by the way here's
a slideshow that I prepared earlier of
extremely graphic images that you're
about to decide that you'll want to go
through yeah but they should tell you
what's going on yeah but do they not
even do they not explain to you that
you're you're gonna have the baby
removed from your body is it they didn't
even explain conditions that you must
surely you have to sign somewhere let
her yeah go ahead they don't even show
you like what it can look like like say
like the stages of the baby they don't
even show you that did you only find
anything they just say the tissues will
come out the tissues they don't even say
a baby or a body or anything just
tissues cells what are they saying do
you sign it off like is it like oh
that's just mad I can't remember if I
was quite long ago um yeah because that
like surely if you signed it like what
are you actually signing like did you
read it you know like is there a lateral
like uh comprehension understanding how
does it work this is part of the
informing process though because like I
mentioned before and as I feel like
everybody would agree on this panel if
you're going in for a procedure in the
hospital everything is explained to you
you your walk through whatever procedure
you're going to have with that
consultant before you get to the
endpoint where you are signing off
because I do remember I did sign a piece
now am I signing that piece of paper
based on being informed properly or am I
signing that piece of paper based on
the other elements that are taking place
and the other
circumstances that has brought me to
that point does that make sense yeah
um so
no doctors are not carefully
um considering
what this woman is going through because
if you did you would then walk her
through that process yeah why are you
why is it such a rest decision to get
her to sign that piece of paper or to
agree to having that abortion
I don't see the duty of care in that um
are we displayed like is it like a given
in all um so like across the board of
all medical procedures in the UK are we
always given pictures and videos of the
procedure that we're about to go under
no but we can at least Google it that's
why so we cannot Google abortion no it's
very hard it's very hard
because we have the pamphlet right there
that displays that's no that's why like
in all honesty that's why I invited her
on because we just made it no because no
because because I I tried to do a
similar like show a couple months ago
and I just thought it was crazy that I
couldn't find videos and pictures at
each stage of the development that was
like clear and actual pictures and
videos of the I I couldn't find it for
the life of me I'm not saying it's not
there but you don't think it's strange
that a procedure that's so common like
the information should be at the top of
Google but it's not and and my mind goes
to why who protects Google's images
like who hides it in Google Matrix The
Matrix The Matrix if you know probably
Google probably even on this show
they'll be there now started doing an
abortion since Roe v Wade was overturned
they've now started doing an abortion
warning just like they did with covid
and vaccination you know if anyone said
anything they they put a you know this
is a link to the NHS so they're doing
the same with abortion
um just that that warning to say that
it's just to try and
get that there's only one kind of
narrative in the NHS and also they don't
really give you like they they need they
kind of like make you rush into it as
well they're kind of like okay so have
you decided okay so you have this Choice
what is it going to be you know it's
like okay like let me think about it you
know and they like when I was quite
Young when I had it done so I was a
child really so how can a child decide
on a child's life if that makes sense
like it it kind of has to have some sort
of age limit as well I think like I
don't know if there's an age limit on
sex then at the same point in time like
do you think the two should go hand in
hand or yeah 100 yeah
yeah
I mean yeah I think we'd agree like 10
too young yeah like at some point there
is a limit I mean I guess
you can't stop them but your parents
should be involved definitely I think
parents are big part to play in this
because just going back to what you're
saying
um like if my daughter was to have a
procedure again I have to keep using
this in line I will definitely have a
part to play in making sure that that
Precision procedure that she's having
I'm happy with it because by law she's
not
I didn't tell my mum yeah neither desire
yeah do you know what I mean but by law
I know she knows now my mom already
knows yeah
um and that was part of my healing
process because I just thought why
should I have to hide that that was a
big part of me do you know what I mean
and I at the point at that time I feel
like I was so I felt like I was so alone
I felt like I had to keep it a secret
why do you know what I mean that was
just Society it was it changed my life
significantly and I feel like I should
have had the support even if I was to
have gone through with it
would you
um
have an abortion now like if I was to
have one that could be yeah sure
that's a good question yeah no I
wouldn't obviously because of the
experiences that I've had obviously I've
taken proportions now I'm so like really
um different about it but yeah no I
wouldn't because how old are you 25 25.
do you um if you could like never had
another child would that make you think
differently about the abortions I I
could never think like that because it
would do I would I'd be depressed and
and if I was to think about the moments
that I've experienced in during
abortions for example like it's
depressing like I would be depressed I
would be like you know I'm unhappy I
just wonder if as many women would abort
their children if like they knew that
they wouldn't have another like if that
was their only child do you think like
women would move the same way that
actually crosses your mind as well when
you are pregnant like you actually think
oh what if you know but
yeah I mean you can't change it you're
right there's no point in like exactly
but I was just curious did you have
children later ah five oh you have five
kids oh that's so nice yeah I have my
first daughter is actually my step
towards her
um
so yeah I'm married obviously as I
stated in the beginning and then my
husband and I have
all together
um well I think we're gonna wrap up the
show it's almost midnight thank you guys
yeah I feel like as many of you know I
was just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible